line thanks emily
the hotline should be in the
communications department
where did the hiss come from i'm not
sure you said the hiss was here when you
entered
did you see anything like that outside
before you came in
no no just inside
the source is internal then see the
oldest house is a sprawling complex with
openings to other places as well i don't
even know where to start looking
but in the context it's good news the
lockdown holds
the hiss escaping the building would be
the end pretty shitty world
out there if you ask me but i wouldn't
want the hiss to destroy it
with you on that emily
you mentioned the oldest house what is
it
this building the bureau headquarters
the oldest house is
a shifting place you've seen it it
transcends its physical limits
i've been to new york a few times
how didn't i notice this it's an
attribute of the building
this is a place of power the oldest
house doesn't like attention so unless
you're purposely trying to find it
you don't which is perfect for us the
work we do here is
essential but unstable the bureau
prefers not to be noticed
and we need strong walls to make sure
nothing gets out
so without you i never would have found
the front door
okay
this trench guy i keep hearing him in my
head
is he a ghost haunting me
i doubt we're talking about a ghost in
the traditional sense
but an echo maybe see if he was killed
by the service weapon
your gun maybe it's his final thoughts
recorded by the bullet in his brain like
a deep space probe sending back data
but that's just a hypothesis on my part
i need the gun to research it
but you better hold on to that given the
circumstances
i think i will yeah
can you tell me what an object of power
is exactly
this is all well new to me
don't worry i love going over the basics
so objects of power are mundane objects
that house paranatural energies
and have developed a link to the astral
plane and can thus be controlled
which is what differentiates them from
altered items which are still housing
supernatural forces
but are more volatile and cannot be
bound in the peritilitarian sense
got it did she memorize this
got it thanks
so hra stop you from becoming hiss
it seems that way i mean i hadn't even
heard of an hra until a few weeks ago
when dr darling started handing them out
well i began analyzing mine as soon as i
got it and each one
seems to emit a powerful short range
frequency way beyond anything i've ever
seen
doesn't the timing seem suspicious
i thought that too dr darling usually
likes to unveil his latest breakthrough
in big
presentations with these he just passed
them out
his behavior makes me wonder what
exactly he knew
thanks emily i'm sure i'll have more
questions soon
just let me know
there it is again our welcome message
communications are on the right track
uh
so
[Applause]
an object of power
so
um
[Music]
it's harder to hear you when i'm here
it's like a channel's been changed
the boards in charge here they're
pyramids in the bureau seal
are they really the ones pulling the
strings
i'm not their director i'm no one's
director
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
ugh
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there you are you were gone cut off
i got
so
foreign
uh
emily said that the hotline can be
reached through the mailroom
is
locked maybe there's a key nearby
this must open the door
foreign
uh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
i have a feeling he'll be back
let's stay focused the hotline should be
past the mailroom
all right take this down the situation
in cuba has been evaluated by the
relevant authorities roberto tomasi
head of commerce the us embassy in
havana was caught by
this got him in the hands of a foreign
power
numerous personnel have damage to the
inner ear but most are expected
to make a full recovery of course the
event also damaged their cellular walls
but
no local doctors examined them first the
hotline can't be far now
the ocean view motel
wow have we been here before
no i've stayed at a lot of roadside
motels across the country on the road
on the run under the radar
this feels like all of them like
something recognized from a dream
the key has a black pyramid on it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it is a phone it's an object of power
it doesn't connect to any typical
network a direct line to the astral
plane
and the board and my hypothesis is
under the right conditions to other
planes of existence as well
a director needs a team my management
team
these people know the secrets of the
bureau as well as i do
some even better darling tomasi
salvador marshall marshall especially
my head of operations she sees right
through me
she knows i don't like relying on people
the only person you should fail is
yourself
but things change when you become
director
i have it the hotline i can reach trench
well listen to him he feels more like an
echo an echo with important
info i need to get back to emily
people react strongly when i tell them
about you
is it too soon to tell emily she might
be able to help
huh
jesse did you get the hotline i mean how
is it out there the calms the hiss
sorry you made it i'm glad
emily let's talk of course
i got the hotline i can make out what
trench is saying now
incredible what did he say
he talked about his management team
people who knew the bureau secrets
your boss darling tomasi but
he's gone that has gone salvador
he's the head of security and marshall
helen marshall is head of operations
she's tough
xcia she took her rangers and went to
the research sector to secure the hra
production
she hasn't come back someone who could
help us
the other sectors how do i get there
it's impossible because of the internal
lockdown you can perform a directorial
override to lift it but that can only be
done in the maintenance sector
normally you take the sector elevator
down there it connects all the sectors
but it won't work while the lockdown is
in effect
we already got past one lockdown maybe
i can find a way
jesse look with no prep no training
in this extreme situation you are doing
phenomenally well and all that and the
hiss can't seem to affect you i mean i
would love to run some tests on you
if you agree that is we could find out
something that would help us
tests i don't know
she might find out about you
but i wouldn't mind understanding more
myself
okay if you think it will help
great i'll check the internal
documentation for any lockdown bypasses
we need to get these sectors open to
locate darling and marshall
and i'll look for a way inside the
maintenance sector the sooner we find
one the sooner i reach this override
you